yeah that's a little easter egg for all
the fans i think the choice was that
actually the darkling just sounds like a
villain yes i
i sort of kept waiting because we were
getting the script as we were going so i
sort of kept waiting for the big reveal
i think it looked amazing it's so
disgusting i remember walking onto set
and
you know some of the the crew hadn't
seen it yet and a couple of extras were
just genuinely going
good girl now the work begins
jesse your performance as alina was
absolutely phenomenal
but i feel like one of the biggest
changes in the book was the staggs
collar it was so much more gruesome and
vicious than the pretty necklace i was
imagining in the books what was your
reaction to that change
oh i was so excited they told me this
and like this was the first week we got
to budapest
and you know they had kind of a couple
of drawings and things to show me and
i just felt it added so much especially
given the
the fact you know the scene where we see
it happening is horrible it's really
horrible you know she's completely
you know they ivan slows her heart rate
so she's not even really conscious and
she's completely like her body is taken
advantage of in that moment and it felt
really raw
and really horrible um and i think it
adds so much to
alina and kerrigan's characters and
their relationship you know there's kind
of
nothing will ever be the same for them
after that and i think it was a really
smart choice because it's so invasive
and it's so horrifying for her
it gave me a lot to work with basically
and i think it looked amazing it's so
disgusting i remember walking on just
that and
you know some of the the crew hadn't
seen it yet and a couple of extras were
just genuinely going
as i came over it really did look
horrible so i think it was just
yeah such a good choice although i
didn't like wearing it but
i was gonna say i imagine the the makeup
process for that is is quite strenuous
it took some it took some time but i
mostly just fell asleep so it was all
good
wait i don't understand a part of that
was um early discussion
with our props team and including our
prosthetics guy
and their concern was we don't like the
idea
that uh anybody could steal your
amplifier they thought you know the
cronenbergian
option of having a more
physical fusion with the grisha
would be more potent and then we had
some practical uh
questions from our costume designer of
if we're going to have jessie
with antler collar for the rest of the
show it's going to create a bunch of
other problems
in terms of just costuming and whatnot
so that came out of
the rigors of uh adapting something it
looks like i look cool
yeah would you like a good change yes
because that's the kind of thing that
you
you know i came up with and in your head
you're like oh and she can cover it with
a scarf but when you really get into
the physicality of that it's very
different and when i first
saw that scene with the the effects
of the darkling putting that collar on
her
it was so powerful and so horrifying and
it
conveys the message of this what is a
very brutal
and dominating act and i thought it was
just extraordinary and i
think it also speaks to things that
happen later in the book series when you
find out when
where the idea of amplifiers came from
it's really a a corruption
of something that grisha used to do so
it to me it was incredibly visceral and
powerful i liked that it was more
invasive and less of an accessory like i
didn't
anticipate that i was going to enjoy it
as much what
are you leigh when i was reading your
books i kept hearing of course
the characters talk so flippantly about
the darkling we hear that term so
often but in the series it's almost like
a
like an insult that's whispered amongst
people we don't hear the term darkling
very often
what are your thoughts on that and
focusing on kiragan rather than the
darkling
i think it really helped to keep him
grounded for viewers
because again there are things you can
get away with in a book particularly a
series that is in the first person
that i don't think would work on the
screen when you have
his troops replying to him and talking
about him when you have foreign
dignitaries talking about him
it telegraphed too quickly and too fully
what his true history
and the extent of his powers are so for
me that was a smart move
to keep him shrouded in a little more
mystery before
the big reveal let us just
make certain we actually do hear him
call the darkling but it's in a little
bit more of a derogatory kind of a way
i think the choice was that actually the
darkling just sounds like a villain in
episode 7 it was so interesting because
we do get to see
your character's backstory something
that we really didn't get to explore in
the book and we really get to kind of
empathize with where he was coming from
what did that mean for you to kind of be
able to add that dimension to your
character
and i think that's exactly why we also
chose to reference that part of the book
where he chose the nobleman's name to to
use in terms of general kirrigan
and the name alexander because i think
it humanizes him to give him a real name
rather than just referring into him as
the darkling which
i think obviously the books are written
in the first person and he's very much
in uh alina's perspective and how he
comes across to her but we wanted to see
a little bit of his experience and how
it all feels for him as well
and so that backstory that we see is not
actually
the back story from the demon in the
woods which is one of the short stories
about him it's it's something that's
fresh for the show
in order to be able to understand a
little bit where the fold has come from
but also that this is a man who's lived
many lives and probably lost many loves
and and tried every way that he can
think of to protect the grisha and the
people that he
cares about so i think it sort of toys
with your sympathies for him in that way
even though the behavior that he's
displaying now
in the series is sort of feels a bit
more unforgivable and i think he's on
balance with the thing that jesse said
about him
chaining elena to to his power
he threw a book at me in episode six it
was so funny when jasper got
hit by a book was that a shadow and bone
book
yeah that's a little easter egg for all
the fans and apparently leigh bardugo
said that was her favorite moment
because we did a read-through
and she laughed out loud just at the
reading of the scene
because the only line in the scene is
hello and then he hit me with a book
she loves the idea of these two
characters meeting who don't meet
beforehand but that book
was a copy of shadow doe in the first
book in wrathkin
and every page was the whole book in
ravkin it's this
legend prop so it's probably worth quite
a lot i imagine
no it was like did you accidentally take
that home with you from set because that
was so cool
i think i think leigh bardugo did and
she definitely gets first dibs
but i was like watching it i like freeze
framed it and like look at my book and i
was like oh my gosh
that's for the true fans and you're one
of them so yeah very impressive
yeah guys hello
[Music]
that is my favorite scene in the whole
series
lee do you have the book i do actually i
do in fact
have that book they asked me you know
would you like something you know would
you like something to and i was like i
know exactly what i want
and in fact i had suggested that
that be the book so i absolutely adore
it
i i love the moment and it really
reminds me of that
gif of melissa mccarthy just pegging
somebody with a book you know
read the book we can let this one go
cast sounds like a trap anyway a trap
would sound easy this is something else
freddy
the way you embodied kaz was just so
spot-on i'm very curious to know how do
you feel about those gloves now after a
season of wearing them and do you wish
we had been able to dive into that a
little bit more in season one
thank you very much first of all i sort
of kept waiting because we were getting
the script as we were going so i sort of
kept waiting for the big reveal as to
or just like a little tease as to why he
needs the gloves or why he feels like he
you know can never take them off so yes
i hope that we get to find out a little
bit more about that initially i didn't
love them the guys will know that i
found it really difficult to do
anything with them on initially they're
meant to be the sort of master of slice
of hand and magic but not quite but by
the end i'd sort of they'd softened up
really beautifully and kind of
they fit like by the end i loved the
blending
of shadow and bone with the six of crows
it really kept
book viewers on our toes because here
are these characters being brought to
life that we've loved so much from the
books
and they're interacting in different
ways and you're just like melding the
story lines
how did you guys even start that fusion
process like was it a long process eric
well it started with the key concept
like that
that idea of what if the crows heist
their job in the first season is to
kidnap alina
and i offered that on a phone call that
i knew that question would either get me
pre-fired
or they'd go all in and you know i
believe lee and the
others sort of gasped after i i gave
that i didn't know if it was a good or a
bad gasp until they said it was a good
guess
it was a good gasp and then it was off
to the races that really
it helped us formulate a lot of what
obstacles
the crows would need to find their way
through the loveliness about
bringing the crows into a book
even a trilogy of books where the pov is
first person from melina's perspective
it granted us a little bit of sort of a
back to the future too
uh you find out how you can replay the
first movie but then add in the
characters that you didn't know were
there
and i guess probably the the most iconic
moment is
at the winter fate where we honor the
fact that
alina still has her own agency and she's
the one to get out
but we just add the twist that it winds
up being in jesper's carriage
i'm not being anyone's captive ever
again
you